Smouse compress my name mark papa
welcome back to some mall Dagon so demon
demon
Dark Souls yes Dark Soul should be here
ok here it is
I got more of them huh this is a trap I
know it oh I told you
hahahaha damn it Smeagol is on you well
at least take me out on that date first
yeah that's the key alright we are going
down huh sure nothing bad will happen
down here what is that guy doing is it
butcher oh it's a steak that I fought
everyone that looks like a nice ass
right there sorry I'm just gonna kill
his dog oh no he's not nice
oh god he's very not nice dog [ __ ] I
don't know why I thought he would be
nice he has a nice belly though is that
a rat that's the Chinese red man hi what
is that oh oh oh damn it's fast kids
you're gonna get poison if you don't do
anything about this [ __ ] or die what is
he doing to that right nay this looks
like a boss area fight let's not go
there
well what's up here imminent safe zone
sure
nice going pits of God now we have to
deal with being down here Oh even more
Oh what the [ __ ] are you Oh God there
why did I fall down here you got it now
pants don't spray it if you don't like
to say it oh God cursed
what oh that's why that we're so easy to
kill and three hours later because I
fell down a [ __ ] cliff I can buy this
[ __ ] stone ah oh thank all that
shit's over
no no no please all God
I should have bought the next I won shed
my okay I don't usually look up stuff
but I don't want to walk all the way for
the [ __ ] cursed [ __ ] and now we're
gonna pretend to be a one of our little
babies she buys it you yes
give me warm give me soft Wow you want
me to poop on you is that it and there
we go we got to purging stones god damn
there's a lot of work to [ __ ] [ __ ] in
this game and we're not curse anymore
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] who would have thought
this might take three years this might
take four years it'll take as many years
as it needs to take its [ __ ] is gonna
die ah oh that was an epic battle indeed
this is gonna get wet and disgusting oh
god what the [ __ ] is out of submarine oh
it's a crocodile love me oh god how the
[ __ ] are we gonna kill oh god it's a
dragon it's a penis croc and it's f oh
oh it's a vagina dragon well I've seen
some scary vaginas but I think that one
is about top setup [ __ ] watch and the
tips
any tips hi I'm gonna go with stab him
in the ass tip worked out great so far
in this game
Oh God that vagina man it's [ __ ]
scary man ah oh yeah there ya ugly I'm
sorry I someone has to tell you I have
two shields I don't know why come on
give me a wet bag and a chop and a chop
could we actually do this [ __ ] on the
first pitch and a chop and a chop oh I'm
so greedy oh god oh god
oh god what the [ __ ] is that what is
help oh oh oh oh god damn it if you make
a medallion puke you know you're doing
something wrong
all right I guess get me finish em come
on no no no look at that house made even
the walls look like a vagina
a dragon medina ironically Oh God come
on don't tell me I'm not the only one
who sees it man this mess is pretty
[ __ ] easy more buses like this one
please that'd be great thanks it's the
most badass looking one and he was
actually Blighttown key universe had
told me about Blighttown hahaha
I don't even know like that was great
too easy alright we look sexy now like I
all right brother so Blighttown in the
next episode
apparently it's a game breaker for a lot
of people you either make it through by
town or you don't
it should be interesting I don't know
anyway they were like you been doing
watching as always appreciate all
support stay awesome bros love you